if you're familiar with our YouTube
channel you probably recognize a few
voices like Sam is always going to use a
map yeah the best videos I always have a
map and Coleman's just going to show you
a photo there's usually other photos in
there Joss is going to drop a bunch of
data on you but make you feel something
if you really think about it our lives
are just line charts these are people
you don't always see on camera but you
might recognize them just by their
voices chip companies moves we see that
the vaccine this is the first famous
photograph as humans each of us produces
a sound that's about as unique as a
fingerprint there has never been
somebody before currently or in the
future that will sound like you so what
is it that makes you sound like you
[Music]
this is your voice box it's called the
larynx and it's located here
the three main functions are to speak to
breathe and to swallow Sandra stennett
is a laryngologist which means she
treats people who have trouble with any
of these we're going to focus on speech
obviously so you have articulatory
function resonance function and then
breath support let's start with breath
if we open it up we can see the larynx
is Hollow when you take a breath in the
air comes down this way into your lungs
when you speak or sing you push air from
your lungs up through your trachea and
through the vocal folds which you might
know as vocal cords laryngologists we
like to call them folds because they're
just they're not chords they're folds
the vocal folds are very very like
pristine white bands they're made up of
mucus covered muscles and cartilage as
air pushes through it forces them open
and then they snap closed and you can
maybe imagine like a water balloon like
if you took two water balloons and
slapped them together and they go that
vibration creates a sound wave the
faster they vibrate the higher pitch the
sound is for men it's about 100 to 200
Waves per second so kind of like a
honeymoon bird wings and then for for
women it's a little bit uh higher
pitched so 200 plus Waves per second so
it's fast if you try to raise the pitch
of your voice
stretch the vocal cords if you think of
having a rubber band and you sort of
pluck
and then you stretch the band a little
bit and then it gets to be a higher
pitch the vocal folds work like that
when we're on a low pitch they're short
and then when we go higher they lengthen
length and lengthen and there's a
different tension that they have next is
where resonance comes in
that sound wave travels through your
larynx and up into your oral and nasal
cavities where it bounces around
this on its own basically produces the
sound of your voice
but to make words we need to shape those
sound waves using articulators
things like our tongues lips teeth and
various other features as humans we all
essentially create sounds in the same
way but differences in the size and
shape of all of these things make our
voices sound different
physiologically we're each incredibly
unique no two larynges are the same
there's I mean that's it's like a
fingerprint all of these different
shapes and sizes contribute to you
having a totally One of a Kind
instrument there are other factors that
play too on top of our physiological
features the brain which is just like
a complicated Circuit of nerves that
manipulate pitch and emotion and
inflection in the voice so you know when
you say hi my name is Sandra or hi my
name is Sandra your life's journey can
impact your voice tremendously where
you've lived what your job is who your
friends are who your family is all of
these factors change the way that you
communicate in the way that you use your
voice so for all of you absolutely
roasting me for this video respect my
journey I grew up in Jersey and then
moved to Long Island I'm lucky I don't
sound like Margot Robbie and Wolf of
Wall Street since our voices are so
specific to who we are it can be pretty
drying when we go through major changes
like in puberty testosterone in
particular can drastically change a
person's voice the men have a more rapid
change in the physiology of their voice
box we see a big change to the vocal
cords they get bigger longer thicker
more muscular and the larynx changes
size and shape too that's why you have
an Adam's apple those kinds of changes
to the vocal folds and larynx can cause
the voice to drop an entire octave but
it's not like you're just stuck there
just like any other muscle we can train
our vocal folds to be more flexible the
more they can stretch The Wider the
range
[Music]
unfortunately as with any muscle your
vocal folds will weaken over time which
is why a lot of elderly people have that
similar shaky raspy or scratchy voice
it's called atrophy and so the vocal
folds themselves have muscles inside and
so they may uh get atrophy I like to
compare it to I'm going to date myself
Coming to America where the guys in the
barbershop
wait a second vocal coaches can help
minimize this atrophy but you can also
make sure you're doing things like
staying hydrated and keeping out of
situations that force you to strain your
voice like yelling or Whispering Your
Voice will inevitably change with time
but that's not necessarily A Bad Thing
The Voice itself is like a fingerprint
but it's also a clue a clue to what type
of person you are whether you're
talkative or not you know where they're
introverted or not I've always thought
that like the larynx was a person's soul
because it's so unique to everybody and
it tells you a lot about a person
[Music]
mama
and then we have
[Music]
way up there so that was an F seven